I am sorry don't hate me I I had car
stuff and then I I couldn't find my keys
you don't get to just blow in here
acting like you care all of a sudden I'm
not
acting Ma's dead read the well
please the mother rarely spoke of a
childhood and she never spoke of it and
she always dodged our questions well in
the end she decided to
talk I had promised myself I would take
all of this with me to my grave I want
to burden you with the weight of it but
I must confess Elanor is not my real
name ki
wait I had to protect you from the life
I was forced to
have I have a way that you can erase all
your debts my daughter is only 16 no
better age for a
wife in order to ensure my safety
[Music]
someone would have to
die none of this makes sense I mean did
Dad know any of this with the stress of
all these secrets Weighing on her she
must have felt so alone for the rest of
my life I'm going to keep looking over
my shoulder what are you running
from betrayal is a powerful thing
but love brings the light that will
guide you out of your darkest moments
how many more secrets was my
[Music]
keeping she has a story our story we
just have to keep listening some secrets
are best left buried here's the past may
it not blow up our
[Music]
present
this is your story
[Music]
too
you'll be the sadest part of me part of
me
[Music]
never tonight is going to be the
lon
[Music]
speee
the sad part of me the part of me that
will never
beight feel me OB
I when I close my
[Music]
eyes
me of me will never
[Music]
beight is going to be the
lonely
let the ember's light brighten a path to
the men I seek guide my steps until I
find them and kill
[Music]
thema
Fowler he was one of the four white men
in Japan when I was born one of them
took my mother and made me a monster
you have murder in your eyes he deserves
to
Die the hurai I saw its eyes it's not
human I want to know everything there is
to know about your
demon he'll come he'll stand right
here and he will open your
throat
under the law revenge is a luxury for
men women must be practical I've been a
captive my whole life fight I today
fight I
[Music]
free I'm On the Path of Revenge there's
no place on it for love friendship or
weakness
under your mask you're not the killer
you pretend to
be you're just
angry I said this Samurai could not be
stopped but you wouldn't
listen just a man let him come he's no
man
[Music]
we all remember that
day for
some the pain will never fade when I was
a kid I always wanted to be my
dad what if that happens
what if I become him and I don't even
know
him I need to do more I can save
lives put me back out
there Mark isn't like other vites he's a
good guy dinner tonight go save the
world Invincible you're way too good for
me who are you I call me the shapes
Smith there's an infinite number number
of dimensions and I was born with the
ability to access all of
them shut it down or I take it down make
us you have no idea how much I wanted
you to say that it's B I'mma let it out
man your powers don't make you a hero
they make you
dangerous make him pay for what he did
to your world last 20 years of my life
have been alive you want this back come
and get it wrong choice
I need
Revenge so arrogant just like your
father people of Earth the more you
resist the worse this
gets and if you think you can stop us
don't forget get
[Music]
I'm you a law man or an
outlaw bit of both I
reckon
I need a man with a good
gun and a straight
spine you up for the
task I wouldn't be sitting here my sonay
best if I wouldn't around these parts we
might be men they're just
Killers all thieves I took an oath to
protect
everyone I ain't about to quit
this
you find a home for
yourself what would you do to hold on to
it to protect it you got to the coun of
fire to get the hell off my leg lady you
got two shells in that bird killer
didn't I just shoot you twice just to be
certain how do I get to do what you do
you're loyal you ain't afraid of much
but the real power lie beneath the
badge ready to ride I thought you'd
never
asked
I'm warning you your wicked days are
done girls here is marriages men party
not particularly in that
order Darlings we always come
verse for certain girls of refinement
New York has become too limited I quite
agree he insists that I invite you and
your daughters to London London London
London for the debutant
ball Americans they're all new money and
I'm quite sure they'll be frightful we
must just grit our teeth and think of
them bucket loads of cash here is T you
world shoulders back head high be
Fearless sorry sorry I'm Nan welcome
fresh from New York imagine a whirlwind
romance with a handsome English Lord of
course you have no interest at all in
being admired I can admire myself can't
i i p to things most people
ignore they're like tattle ra hop I
think they're lovely yes they are lovely
but they're also human beings who are
funny and
smart girls that generally meet don't
think or talk so freely or so
passionately imagine not realizing
you're in the presence of a Duke oh is
this are you what I am as aaff as a give
me one good reason why you couldn't be a
duchess I can't possibly what actually
is the
Dess this is Guy wart my oldest friend
you've met
[Music]
yes she moves in such an unexpected way
res have you noticed yeah I'm a perf all
am thef all am girls are taught
that if a story isn't a love story it's
a tragedy I know I know we have
us and what if this is our love
story
I'm
all goodness what a lady you are all
I've ever wanted to
[Music]
be we go on the tour record an EP walk
into that lab get a million
deal hey I brought some bad from
the 305 with me is baked and ready to
come out the oven okay
dang right back in right back in I heard
the West needed a little rain drip drip
I know the with Raina is a lie
let's make an Oreo bch you stupid really
stupid it's three bad no it's
two bad and a old bottle of
Pepto
biso I'm the one that's been helping
with that career you have no business
managing anybody you can barely manage
them little braids do you know who
you are you over here with the scarcity
mindset you need to have an abundance
mindset I'm going be ducking like
Li
[Music]
Kim got means with my artist without
me okay sh KN they don't need you I'm
going to make sure they know
that you was just on the PO and then now
you on the bus going state to state I
got a chance at some you really
going to play my face like that figure
it out by yourself mace is facing
federal charges I'm still trying to
figure out how we even got here I was
not the only one that needed money keep
your distance from morce every time I
get a win for y'all y'all still treat me
like a loser it going to be successful
if our manager pimping imagine if you
took all the energy you was using over
there and brought it over here who
speaks for you says everything together
we can take this to the next level
so you dressed them
[Music]
now on out it's go big or go
home it's our time down on
my you was born to do this let everybody
else say something different I'll beat
that ass what you going to
[Music]
do the Russians put the first man on the
moon that steps away from nuclear war
There's No Going Back a three-way race
to Mars we're not going to come in
second place again today we take the
next step towards a self sustaining Mars
[Music]
colony they're looking for guys just
like us this job is on Mars I could be
doing something that I never even
dreamed
of for the next two years of your life
Mars is your new home take me out what's
happened so something incredible this
asteroid it could change everything for
people back home there's more aridium in
the asteroid than has been mined in the
entire history of Earth I you we can
capture the most valuable known object
in our solar system North Korean CIA KGB
they're all wanting a piece of this pie
is this about Justice or filling your
pockets what are you going to do with
all that money if you're dead I always
thought I'd go out place of Glory take
me
I'm going to get that rock or die trying
we are powerless up here a million miles
from my family this isn't what it was
supposed to be people are going to keep
getting hurt well your bank accounts
grow bigger and
bigger building a new world for our
future you ready to make history always
my
friend take me
out
[Music]
there's no such thing as a perfect City
but to me this city is as close as it
comes that's why we're proud to call
Espanola my home oh our home all
right you got it it's
okay this isn't your typical home
flipping show my homes are reflecting
the local
community and we're husband and wife
this is
kind so w get go
wrong let's grab a quick shot of you um
giving money to that little girl over
there we're doing good here we are good
people thank you we're really good got
it so all I had on me was that $100 bill
no refunds that's not fair come on let
me go get change and what is that that's
nothing this is you don't need to see
this why did you snatch back the money
why didn't you just give her the 100 I
was going to buy Six of them for $20 I
curse you what did she say i
p
what what things have been a little
weird I just need this thing that you're
doing right now it's helping the
community it's immune to
criticism hi oh Marjorie can speak to
the work much better than I can I think
I'll let the work speak for
itself
[Music]
just cuz Whitney has a moral issue with
something that's happening we just toss
it
away this doesn't make
sense hi um is everything
okay maybe this is all happening for a
reason
I can't wait for this show to come
out everyone will get to see who you
really
[Music]
are you know you can tell me anything
right of
[Music]
course Strange Love
I sometimes
wonder would it have been
better not to
[Music]
go I think about it like a coin toss
times when their life when my CRI can go
one way see
[Music]
unforgivable
or
another when they're
trapped at the end of the world you have
to make
this there's no going back
welcome it's so exciting to see you all
here no
Escape
[Music]
I think there's something going on
here that we don't fully
understand why is it wherever you go
death
follows to finding a way
[Music]
out
don't really understand how I ended up
[Music]
here dashing
around losing sight of myself in the
process you know I think that's been the
story of my whole
life
I'm afraid your
majesty interest in the princess's
private life is unlikely to die down
anytime soon the Press are on our Tails
constantly all one wants is for that
girl to find
[Music]
peace
mommy you
okay I'm okay
[Music]
it's
just it has all been a bit mad
[Applause]
recently you finally succeeded in
turning this house upside
down it's nothing less than Revolution
that's never my
intention
set against a background of Roar emotion
the royal family remains silent what do
people want from
me for you to be mother to the
nation you've seen the images on the
television Dina gave people what they
needed all over the world in their
thousands and they had daughter for it
this is going to be the biggest thing
that any us has ever
[Music]
seen we did well today s Kai it would be
a feast it'll be a night to
remember well that's disappointing more
blood H than
fish silly we're
home wrong
show that French chef of yours is really
something pretty extraordinary my board
was content with nothing when all we had
was nothing but now that we have
something we want more something and
less
nothing don't
talk we need new content yesterday Alice
I am disappointed I want to take on
subjects of great magnitude Vietnam we
inform you decide while you are working
on the details of this one show I'm
tasked with saving the entire
station Hunter wants to do something
called product placement how much do you
stand to make from all this quite a lot
may not be the best episode for that
knife
though what an Earth has been happening
here while I was gone friendship is a
two-way
street I put up with you put up with me
I feel like I'm losing track of who I am
I may have some surprises at my sleeve
Paris home I married the right guy
you're wasting our time with that dish
we have to make compromises I came here
for some relief not to play referee
between the two of
you oh my God you must try the little
per next no I will not be seduced by
shelf you're a wonderful woman
succeeding a mediocre man's world if you
feel like a punching bag you've never
been punched my dear we sold in 12 more
markets Chicago phly we want to bring
the French chef over to CBS oh what are
you going to say Julia is going to take
WTB behind the scenes into the White
House
[Music]
kitchen I feel like I'm a virgin all
over again well it was until a moment
ago go ahead and take
monor was there in San
Francisco when the whole city was coming
down these guys were taking pictures
like they'd been waiting for
it you think that your father was
working for them this stuff wasn't a
safe who are they what's monarch
there's a
new this is the world we live in
monsters are an inescapable
reality those files belong to us and
they are more important than you could
possibly
imagine
there's this is going to give me
nightmares now you can choke down that
Monarch live
[Music]
about your father disappearing
with or we can find out what really
happened before it's too
[Music]
late oh my God go go go this world it's
not ours believe
me is so much more vast than we could
possibly
imagine these monsters and Monarch have
taken everything from
me no
more the world is on fire if you want to
save millions of lives we can use some
help
re
new
[Music]
come
ramanda the girl of my
dreams it's time to wake up
dude I had a dream about that girl again
I didn't care the first time you told me
care even less now Toronto
Canada not too long
ago hey want to go out sometime
you want to go on a date with me Ramona
Flowers has seven Evo exes all of whom
you must defeat in order to date her
what Scott
kill
Scott PGM Ramona Flowers Matthew pel
Wallace Wells Lucas Lee Stacy BG
in Kim pie this info dump was inevitable
power inra gide
gra Steven Stills Roxy rer KN
cow
off let's
[Music]
party well sir there's no easy way to
say this
um your wife isn't who she says she is
let me tell you what I
[Music]
see I
see a woman who outsmarted two
kidnappers are you okay
ma'am never do you
mention she is a
tiger she's claiming it never happened
never what now she's a the wolf and
sheep's cloth in that one honestly I'm
embarrassed by all the
fuss there is no one on God's green
earth who is a greater enforcer of the
laws of this land than Roy
Tillman why do I feel like there's a
butt here
but you got any Weaponry back
there got an air
horn all of you people sneaking around
here pretending you're so nice but I
know who you really are I'm a winner
that don't sound accurate I'm a winner
yeah my
[Music]
ass better sleep with both eyes
open cut it out cut it out cut it out
cut it
out it's good to see you again Mrs lion
that wasn't me first of all I'm I
recognize you you were kidnapped and for
the record that's just reality with all
due respect we've got our own reality
you
can't that's not a
thing fx's Fargo premieres November 21st
on FX stream on
Hulu